una propuesta que incomoda unas 80.000
personas salieron a las calles de tel
aviv a manifestarse en contra de los
planes de reforma judicial del recién
posesionado al gobierno de Benjamín
netanyahu
vine aquí para manifestarme en contra de
las medidas antidemocráticas del nuevo
gobierno en Israel están tratando de
destruir la estructura democrática del
Estado israelí están trabajando en
contra el artículo de la independencia
que es la base de la democracia israelí
las protestas que ya completan varios
días también fueron seguidas en las
ciudades de haifa y Jerusalén Durante
los primeros días del 2023 el ministro
de Justicia israelí yarif levin anunció
un plan con el cual Busca reducir los
poderes de la Corte Suprema politizar el
nombramiento de jueces reducir la
independencia de los asesores legales
del gobierno entre otros estos cambios
podrían ayudar a netanyahu quienes
juzgado por corrupción adir su condena o
incluso hacer que el juicio desaparezca
por completo los detractores de la
Reforma aseguran que esta paralizaría la
independencia judicial y fomentaría la
corrupción además de afectar los
derechos de las minorías
creo que es importante que existan
contrapesos en la democracia me preocupa
que la supuesta reforma que están
tratando de aprobar esté socavando los
controles de La Libertad israelí El
Primer Ministro israelí ahora en su
sexto mandato ha tratado de dar calma a
los opositores asegurando que el plan se
implementaría luego de escuchar todas
las posiciones la Kenneth es decir el
parlamento votará la decisión final